Salut, aujourd'hui on est samedi et le samedi c'est le jour du Master Class'
depuis le début de l'année le samedi et le Master Class' ça sert à apprendre un truc un peu plus consistant
un peu plus concret, un petit peu plus poussé
C'est encore le cas aujourd'hui même si ça va être un petit peu différent
1ère différence:
Vous n'aurez pas manqué de constater qu'il va être 11h30 quand la vidéo sortira
parce que ce matin à la dernière minute j'ai changé mes plans
et j'ai décidé de faire cette vidéo. Celle que je suis en train de faire
2ème différence:
Le rapport entre ce Master Class' et le mentalisme est un tout petit peu différent de d'habitude
puisque le vrai sujet de ce Master Class' c'est l'intermittence du spectacle
et comment on arrive à vous manipuler pour vous faire croire que ce sont des gros branleurs
Depuis des années on voit les communications de certains médias ou alors du Medef
dire les intermittents coûtent chers, les intermittents sont des privilégiés
et chose, qui me fait encore plus mal et qui m'a motivé à faire cette vidéo ce matin.
C'est de voir d'autres artistes défendre notre cause et en fait se tromper sur la manière de défendre notre cause
puisque dans les vidéos que je vois passer, on oublie de dire l'essentiel
Avant de vous expliquez la magnifique et subtile manipulation à base de détournement d'attention et de mathématiques
parce que celle ci elle est tellement magnifique qu'il faut que je vous la raconte après
Il faut que je pose une base simple
Intermittents du spectacle n'a jamais été un statut social
C'est une annexe chez pôle emploi. Il y a l'annexe 8, y'a l'annexe 10
c'est un moyen d'indemnisation
C'est à dire qu'on a pas une caisse pour nous qui s'occupe des intermittents
Non
on fait parti de la solidarité inter-professionnelle
c'est à dire que chaque intermittent qui travaille,
paie ses cotisations comme tout le monde
il le met dans la cagnotte des cotisations inter-profesionnelles
et ensuite ceux qui ne travaillent pas touche une indemnité
mais comme n'importe qui.
Et vous allez me dire pourquoi on a créé des annexes spécifiques
et bien c'est une bonne question,
c'est un peu comme l'annexe 4, qui ont bien morflé, d'ailleurs, aux dernières négociations.
on en a pas trop parlé, ça ceux sont les intérimaires.
Il y a des annexes spéciales, parce que la manière de travailler est spéciale
c'est à dire qu'on travaille en discontinuité
On ne travaille pas chaque jour de la semaine
On ne travaille pas selon le système standard
Aujourd'hui quelqu'un qui travaille dans le système général peut travailler
durant plusieurs mois, plusieurs années en CDI ou en CDD
Et à un moment donné, être au chômage, pendant 1 an, 2 ans, 2 ans et demi etc...
Evidemment, ça ne peut pas s'appliquer à un rythme de travail discontinu
tel que celui des artistes et des techniciens
donc ils ont créé des annexes pour ça
Pour avoir une solution pour nous indemniser
Cette solution c'est que nous avons un quota d'heures à réaliser durant une période de 10 mois et demi maximum
Et, si nous réalisons ce quota d'heure, nous sommes indemnisés pendant 243 jours
Tout en sachant que si je fais un spectacle alors j'ai une journée et demi d'indemnisation qui me sera retiré
Je ne vais pas trop rentrer dans les détails.
L'idée vraiment à retenir c'est qu'en fait intermittents du spectacle, n'est pas un statut, c'est une catégorie chez pôle emploi
c'est une annexe chez pôle emploi
qui a été créé parce que notre rythme de travail est spécifique. Donc il fallait une manière de nous indemniser, spécifique.
Elle est loin de nous privilégiez, personnes n'a envie de notre place en réalité je vous assure.
Deuxième point à retenir avant de vous parlez de cette grosse manipulation.
Les intermittents du spectacle ne sont pas que des gens qui font du spectacle vivant.
Tous les films que vous voyez, les émissions radio qui vous aimez écouter, les journaux, souvent, que vous lisez
les spectacles que vous allez voir
Tous ce qui a un rapport avec la culture, a un rapport avec le système d'indemnisation des intermittents du spectacle
Pour un film, il faut des scénaristes, des dialoguistes etc...
D'ailleurs, il faut savoir que eux n'ont pas le droit à l’intermittence.
Ils ont aucune assurance chômage alors qu'ils paient énormément de cotisations pour autres choses.
Les cadreurs, les tourneurs, les monteurs, les comédiens, bien souvent les maquilleurs, les coiffeuses, alors que ça c'est interdit d'ailleurs
sont intermittents du spectacle
L'intermittent du spectacle n'est pas que celui qui est sur scène dans un petit théâtre de 20 places
Mais lorsqu'on dit: "Si y'a plus le régime de l'intermittence, on tue la culture"
Je n'suis pas d'accord
Ce qu'on tue surtout
c'est le droit à l'indemnisation.
Je rappelle encore une fois que nous cotisons.
Nous cotisons aux caisses de l'assurance chômage
Il y a 110 000 intermittents en France.
y a 110 000 intermittents, y a à peu près
4 intermittents sur 10 qui sont indemnisés chaque mois
4 sur 10
et c'est pas spécifique à l'annexe 8, à l'annexe 10
C'est le cas pour tout les chômeurs.
Il y a à peu près 4 chômeurs sur 10 qui sont indemnisés chaque mois en France.
Et là, attention on va se régaler
au niveau de la manipulation à travers les chiffres
Je vous rappelle ce qu'on vous présente.
On vous dit, et c'est vrai, que les intermittents du spectacle représente 3,4% des chômeurs. C'est une réalité
Et que l'indemnisation de ces 110 000 intermittents ça coûte 1 milliard d'euros
C'est vrai aussi
Et enfin, on nous explique que l'Unedic, que pôle emploi est déficitaire de 1.5 milliard d'euros
C'est vrai aussi, c'est une réalité
donc on vous présente la conclusion suivante:
Les 110 000 intermittents, qui représente uniquement 3,4% des chômeurs
sont responsables de 75% du déficit
C'est magique
Mais moi je vais vous rajouter quelques autres informations
La 1ère c'est que 100 000 chômeurs indemnisés, quel qu’ils soient.
Que ce soit des bouchers, des mécanos, des secrétaires, peu importe
100 000 chômeurs indemnisés coûtent 1 milliard d'euros
qui soit intermittents du spectacle ou pas.
On avait pas oublié de le préciser ça !
Et comparer ce que coûte 1 branche professionnelle par rapport au déficit
N'a aucun sens.
Si je fais la même démonstration sur 100 000 artisans, par exemple.
Je vais obtenir le même calcul, hein.
Je vais dire, ben voilà, 100 000 artisans ça coûte 1 milliard d'euro alors que le déficit il est de 1,5 milliard d'euro.
Depuis quand on compare ça avec un déficit?
En plus, de ça quand on calcule le coût d'1 milliard d'euros, on calcule juste les dépenses,
Parce... en fait, on avait cotisé, à un moment donné.
Et, on... on l'avait pas redis ça
dans la démonstration
Un petit calcul très simple, qui devrait vous plaire aussi
qui date de 2011.
En 2011, la différence entre les cotisations perçues et les indemnités versées, d'un point de vue générale de tout pôle emploi, de tout l'Unedic.
était de 4.5 milliard d'euro
d’excédent je parle
4.5 milliard d'euro de cotisations en plus que ce qui est sorti
Qu'est ce que tu as fait de tout ce pognon Pôle
Donc il y avais 4.5 milliard d'euro d’excédent entre les cotisations et ce qu'on ressortait
Mais le fonctionnement général, de toute l'activité pôle emploi/ Unedic
était de 6 milliard d'euro
6 milliard d'euro, donc en 2011 on a fini avec un déficit d' 1,5 milliard d'euro
Sur ce coup là, j'ai quand même tendance à dire que c'est Pôlo qui est lui même responsable de son propre déficit
Parce que niveau cotisation, ça allait pour tout le monde. Là, je parle pour les intermittents mais je parle de toutes les branches
professionnelles quelles qu’elles soient
Je précise, parce que ça aussi on avait apparemment oublier d'en parler, en gros, dans les journaux
Sur sa page facebook Samuel Churin, qui fait  énormément, énormément, énormément
pour les intermittents mais aussi pour les précaires d'une manière générale.
Explique que le coût de fonctionnement de pôle emploi coûte 10% des recettes des cotisations qui arrive chaque année. Soit 3 milliard d'euro en ce moment même où je vous parle.
euh...
parce que c'est beaucoup quand même 3 milliard d'euro, enfin
Faut, faut revoir des trucs, faut acheter un peu moins de stylos, je sais pas ou
ou faut envoyer moins de courrier, en fait
Mais il y a un problème c'est pas compétitif ça vous savez
Le grand jeu de certain syndicat et de certain média c'est d'agiter un petit peu le côté: Voilà ils coûtent très très chers les intermittents
C'est pas vrai, c'est un mensonge, on vient de le voir c'est une manipulation en réalité.
Ce n'est pas un système spécifique privilégié, une caisse à part
C'est du chômage en fait.
C'est tout simplement le droit au chômage
après avoir cotisé.
Ce n'est viable et stable dans le temps, c'est à dire que c'est pas agréable et confortable d'être dans ce système là. On est toujours remis en question
L'indemnisation est assez faible
Et c'est un vrai combat de tous les jours pour savoir quand on va renouveler, indemniser.
Je passe ma vie à expliquer aux copains comment ça fonctionne parce que c'est très très compliqué à comprendre
et donc au delà même de la culture, on parle bien de toute l'indemnisation chômage, en général.
Je pense que ce sujet méritait un Master Class' . J'espère que ça vous servira un petit peu, à y voir un petit plus clair
dans cette nébuleuse de "c'est quoi ces artistes, l'intermittence etc..."
Samedi prochain on reviendra sur du Master Class' plus classique
et je vous tease. Je vous parlerai de comment réussir vos examens!
parce que ça arrive bientôt
Demain c'est dimanche donc ça sera plus cool.
Je vais vous expliquer un tour pour bluffer vos amis
et sinon c'est toujours 1 vidéo par jour pendant 1 an depuis ce 1er janvier jusqu'au 31 décembre
Donc rendez vous demain à 11h pour le prochain Mental Vlog
Ciao!